bonjour et bienvenue à l'entretien de
France 24 notre invité aujourd'hui est
un journaliste fin connaisseur du mandar
arabe du ma Shrek l'Orient et du Maghreb
aussi auteur de ce livre
Qatar les secrets d'une influence
planétaire en 100 questions par eu
récemment aux éditions talandiers
Christian chez nous bonjour bonjour
Alors Christian chez nous merci d'être
venu à France 24 pour cette interview
c'est votre quatrième livre sur le Qatar
vous avez écrit avec George malbruno
grand porteur au Figaro trois autres
livres cathares pipers nos très chers
émirs et aussi cathare les secrets du
coffre-fort pourquoi le Qatar le Qatar
parce que c'est un pays fascinant qui
n'existait pas il y a 20 ans et qu'on
découvre aujourd'hui j'allais dire en
pleine lumière parce qu'il organise la
Coupe du Monde c'est quand même quelque
chose d'extraordinaire un pays donc
fulgurant dans le des relations
internationales un pays qui nous
intéresse nous Français parce qu'il
investit beaucoup en France et puis un
pays qui est majeur parce que encore une
fois il est il est sur toute sur tous
les fronts diplomatiques sportif
économique médiatique culturelle donc je
trouve c'est un pays qui qui est un peu
la un laboratoire de la de la
mondialisation on retrouve tout au Qatar
les bonnes choses et j'allais dire aussi
les mauvaises de la mondialisation de la
Poste mondialisation le débat est grand
un petit pays qui regarde le monde et
qui est qui est avide de trouver sa
place et d'exister un peu comme
Singapour ou d'autres pays étincelants
donc vous parlez d'une ascension à
fulgurante une story comme vous dites
principalement grâce à un homme
visionnaire mais aussi opportuniste
Hamad ben Khalifa alfani qui est cet
homme et pourquoi cette ambition hors
quand il prend le pouvoir en 95 en fait
c'est j'allais dire c'est une revanche
par rapport à son frère à son père chez
Khalifa qui voulait faire du Qatar
finalement presque une province
saoudienne chez Hamad qui est jeune qui
voit à côté Dubaï avec ses gratte-ciel
avec ses grands mots ses autoroutes
cette monnaie modernité lui explique et
nous on a on a plein de gaz qui dort
sous le golfe Persique on partage avec
l'Iran on l'utilise pas nous on reste en
gros dans le sable donc c'est pour ça
qu'il renverse son père cher Khalifa en
95 et la vision de chez Ramat c'est
justement de poser le Qatar sur la carte
d'utiliser ses ressources en
l'occurrence le gaz pour rayonner pour
encore une fois étinceler sur la scène
mondiale et dans tous les domaines
encore une fois économique sportive
culturel diplomatique et là c'est
presque une revanche qui va prendre le
sheraman sur sur son père et aussi sur
les voisins émiriens comme Dubaï mais
c'est intéressant de voir cette soif de
reconnaissance dans le golfe oui parce
que le Qatar c'est le dernier élève de
la classe où on découvre les isocarbures
le gaz notamment la grande découverte du
gaz au
Qatar c'est 1971 les autres Koweït
Arabie Saoudite et mirabari ils
connaissent le pétrole déjà depuis les
années 30-40 50 les pétrodollars ont
ruisselé sur ces pays et donc le Qatar
c'est je disais le dernier relève de la
classe et donc il a presque une soif de
revanche sur ces sur les voisins dire
moi aussi je suis riche moi aussi je
peux me développer moi aussi je suis
indépendant tant que vous c'est
intéressant dans votre livre vous
diagnostiquez la diplomatie la manière
de faire des catariens vous dites vous
parlez de diplomatie de carnet de
tchèques au Qatar mais plus loin en
Libye par exemple vous parlez aussi
d'une influence un soft power avec
politique ceci médiatique bancaire et
pouvez également au niveau du sport on
le voit avec le PSG alors pourquoi ça
choquerait quand il s'agit d'un pays
comme le Qatar et que ça choquerait
moins pour un autre pays c'est le propre
de la diplomatie non locataire
évidemment comprendre que pour exister
il a pas d'armée une armée de 12000
hommes et ils font pas le poids enfin
par rapport aux Iraniens aux Irakiens ou
au saoudiens donc chez arma se dit
comment je vais construire ce pouvoir
comment je peux rayonner et évidemment
il fait ce soft power alors tout va bien
quand on est dans la médiation quand on
est dans l'investissement quand on est
dans le le culturel on construit des
musées on construit la la cité de
l'éducation au Qatar et puis c'est vrai
qu'on commence à être borderline j'ai
dit on franchit les lignes rouges
notamment dans les printemps arabes ou
algésira devient finalement le
porte-parole du kata et des
révolutionnaires pas toujours j'allais
dire modéré moi je me souviens très très
bien le le chef de la branche d'Al-Qaïda
en Syrie monsieur jolany avec quasiment
antenne ouverte sur les Ant
qui joue ils vont jouer un peu avec le
feu c'est à dire que leur diplomatie de
médiation c'est de rapprocher les gens
va se transformer en un outil pour
changer le monde arabe mais parfois pas
avec les les gens les plus démocrates
les plus modérés on l'a vu en Libye ils
ont livré 20000 tonnes d'armes à la
révolution libyenne au modéré mais aussi
à des gens recommandables avec des
djihadistes des djihadistes des gens
dans le cahella donc après c'est vrai
quand vous jouez un peu sur tous les
tableaux et ben à la fin vous pouvez
vous brûler en France on l'avait révélé
avec Jordan Bruno avec notre bouquin à
4h papers quand vous commencez à
financer les mosquées les associations
des Frères musulmans en France environ
30 millions 22 projets bah vous
commencez à jouer avec le feu c'est pas
simplement on rachète le PSG et on
rachète le royaume Monceau on commence à
à toucher presque l'ADN du pays et donc
les gens bah ça suscite des réactions
des des interrogations avec une question
mais que veut le Qatar quel est votre
agenda simplement c'est faire du
business ou essayer pas prendre le
contrôle communauté musulmane en France
et ça évidemment il y a eu un grand flou
une opacité les cathariens comme souvent
dans le golf d'ailleurs ils sont pas des
bavards ils donnent Pauline interview et
donc en France il y a eu beaucoup
d'interrogations sur le rôle du Qatar
justement ce qui nous frappe dans ce
livre c'est ce dualisme ce double jeu
d'une part investir dans la culture dans
le sport et d'autre part financer les
Frères musulmans et puis aussi cette ADN
wahhabiste qui qui est lié au Qatar
justement
Christian chez nous que veut le Qatar
bah justement ils veulent de l'influence
c'est à dire qu'ils veulent être reconnu
et la Coupe du monde ça sert à ça j'ai
dit c'est c'est l'apothéose pour les
meilleurs Tamines ils veulent être
reconnus encore une fois sur la période
printemps arabe ils ont joué avec le feu
je pense qu'ils ont été victimes de leur
succès ils ont pensé que finalement tout
s'achète et ça c'était un peu la la j'ai
dit la devise de Ahmed Ben jassen qui
était les ancien Premier ministre
l'ancien patron de la diplomatie
catharienne qui était vraiment l'homme
qui a fait rayonner le Qatar aussi à
l'étranger et pour lui tout s'achète il
suffit de mettre le prix donc à partir
de là oui on peut acheter mais ça ça
provoque aussi des réactions et donc
voilà l'achat d'influence pourquoi pas
mais à un moment donné il faut il faut
être je veux dire réaliste et le
problème du Qatar c'est que c'est un
petit pays on l'a pas dit mais 300000
habitants j'allais dire une rue du Caire
ou une rue d'Alger grand comme la Corse
et vous voulez vous comparer à l'Égypte
à l'Arabie saoudite à l'Irak à l'Iran il
y a un moment donné il y a eu une
contradiction entre le poids réel du
Qatar et son poids d'influence qui est
énorme alors aujourd'hui ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il reprend encore
de la Bigueur avec la crise en Ukraine
et le gaz les prix qui explosent pour le
Qatar c'est une bénédiction mais
justement quelle marche de manoeuvre et
surtout quelle influence encore pour le
Qatar en France et en Europe ah bah
l'influence va continuer à grandir alors
en Europe les Cathar
voilà vont moins privilégier l'Europe
pour les investissements ils ont fait
beaucoup de choses je rappelle c'est 45
milliards d'euros d'investissements en
Angleterre 25 en France 25 en Allemagne
ils sont aussi en Italie en Suisse et en
Espagne maintenant leurs investissements
ils veulent j'allais dire qu'ils soient
planétaire ils vivent aujourd'hui
l'Amérique les États-Unis et surtout
toute l'Asie c'est-à-dire l'un le
Pakistan jusqu'à la Chine la Corée le
Japon l'Indonésie donc il y a il y a un
peu
et l'Afrique voilà et des pays africains
donc l'Europe je crois que maintenant et
notamment la France c'est c'est presque
devenu un lieu de vie des jeture bon ils
ont leur la famille régnante et le tany
à tous ces quartiers d'été à au-dessus
de Cannes sur la Côte d'Azur ils vont
continuer à venir ils ont des
appartements des hôtels particuliers à
Paris ils vont continuer mais ils vont
aussi diversifier leurs investissements
au-delà de l'Europe concernant la Coupe
du Monde ce sera la dernière question
c'est une première pour un pays musulman
un pays arabe les critiques qui sont ici
en France concernant cette organisation
de mondiale 2022 et perçue par le Qatar
et les pays arabes comme étant une sorte
d'islamophobie est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée de boycotter le Mondial non
je pense que le boycott n'est pas une
bonne idée c'est même contre-productif
le vrai problème le vrai scandale c'est
la FIFA la FIFA qui donne évidemment le
le Mondial un pays qui connaît pas le
sport dans un pays désertique on
s'aperçoit deux ans après qui fait chaud
l'été il fait 50 degrés on va pas
pouvoir jouer donc il faut il faut
déplacer le tournoi en décembre la FIFA
qui n'a pas mis de cahier des charges
sur l'environnement sur les droits
humains sur les travailleurs donc le
scandale il est là après le Qatar il
joue sa partition c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les critiques il y a
beaucoup d'hypocrisie et d'ailleurs les
catharniens nous disent c'est vrai que
vous français vous voulez pas de fazzone
et vous voulez le gaz du Qatar donc il y
a un moment donné il y a aussi des
contradictions chez nous parce que le
carter c'est aussi le miroir de nos
fantasmes miroir de l'argent de l'argent
roi parce que encore une fois le pays
est immens sont riches alors que la
France l'Europe est un peu en déclin le
miroir aussi sur les valeurs sur l'Islam
sur les droits de la femme etc donc une
espèce de jeu de miroir déformant et
donc tous les fantasmes tous les clichés
de part et d'autre d'ailleurs je pense
que les katariens aussi ne comprennent
pas français la France et vice-versa
donc il y a des incompréhensions et donc
cette coupe du monde elle a lieu au
Qatar pourquoi pas c'est vrai que Michel
Platini à l'époque avait dit que c'était
une candidature loufoque mais finalement
elle va se jouer voilà il l'a soutenu
voilà c'est pour ça on en a la France a
soutenu par l'intermédiaire de Nicolas
Sarkozy qui était le président de la
République à l'époque il a soutenu le
Qatar donc après 10 ans après on se dit
ah bah non faut pas de coupe du monde
là-bas donc voilà c'est un peu j'allais
dire beaucoup d'hypocrisie le Qatar il y
a des critiques à faire le Qatar c'est
aussi amélioré sur les travailleurs etc
mais voilà c'est un peu voilà comment on
dit on est on est un petit peu dans
cette hypocrisie on veut pas voilà ça
nous embête de voir un pays un petit
pays avoir une coupe du monde même si
effectivement il y a des critiques
Christian chez nous merci merci à vous
merci à vous également d'avoir regardé
cet entretien sur France 24 bientôt
[Musique]